gebt euch diese hose ich weiß nicht ob
man das sehen kann
aber die hat einfach klar muss man ja
sehen die hat einfach genau wie ich will
das gar nicht anfassen genau da ein loch
genau im schritt ein loch dinger was
hast du damit gemacht was geht ab und
jetzt willkommen bei einem neuen video
ja leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut ich bin wirklich sehr froh dass ich
jetzt hier sitzen und das video für euch
aufnehmen kann denn es war gar nicht mal
so leicht ich weiß nicht ob ihr den
ersten paar davon gesehen hab ich halt
diesen ersteigerten koffer ausgepackt
habe ich habe mich gefragt ob wir bock
drauf habt und das hattet ihr
anscheinend also dass jedes echt gut
angekommen hat mich sehr gefreut weil
ich persönlich fand es auch so
interessant und ja ich habe mich auf die
suche gemacht zu der nächsten koffer im
auktion die gibt es natürlich in ganz
deutschland allerdings nicht zumindest
jetzt nicht diese ganz krassen großen
die man vielleicht auch aus dem
fernsehen kennt also ich bin eigentlich
noch mal darauf bekommen weil ich das im
fernsehen gesehen hab halt so ein
bericht darüber es werden allerdings
monatlich an größeren bahnhöfen auch
aktionen gestartet mit dem kopf an die
an bahnhöfen liegengeblieben sind usw
und heute habe ich einen koffer dabei
ich kann ihr euch mal kurz zeigen einen
schwarzen eigentlich ist es hier
ziemlich dunkel sowie haben wir diesen
schwarzen trolley ganz normale
handgepäcks käufer was beim letzten mal
auch oder meiner tasche waren keine
ahnung habe ich für 60 euro bekommen
also eigentlich wirklich günstig wobei
man auch sagen muss der körper macht
nicht mehr so das beste erscheinungsbild
das hier ist abgebrochen also
funktioniert gar nicht mehr wirklich man
kann nur so auf dem boden schieben aber
das muss ja gar nicht heißen dass nur
müll drin ist bevor sich jetzt wieder
einige sperren und sagen alex solar was
viel zu lange ich bin euch hier mal kurz
die zeit ein wo das video losgeht wo ich
den koffer auspacken
ich wollte allerdings zuvor noch ein
paar wichtige sachen sagen gerne zu den
koffer aktion deswegen würde ich jedem
empfehlen sich das kurz anzuhören dauert
vielleicht ein zwei minuten und zwar
gleich erstmal das wichtigste vorweg
wenn ihr bock habt es ist am 25
glaube ich eine kaufoption ich muss
jetzt sehen sagen wo ich sag mal so wenn
dieses video jetzt auch wieder gut
ankommen sollte und es sich wirklich
lohnt ein video darüber zu machen dann
fahre ich wirklich sehr gerne diese 250
kilometer und nehmen auch ein bisschen
mehr geld in die hand und ersteigern
keine ahnung sagen wir vier oder fünf
koffer mir das vielleicht ein bisschen
viel sagen wir drei kopf die man halt
dann alle auch noch auspacken kann also
wenn ihr bock drauf habe dass auf jeden
fall einen drogen gleich wird einfach
mal sagen weil zehn tagen nichts machen
wir das und auch ganz wichtig abonniert
den kanal nicht zu verpassen weil ich
habe auch gesehen bei mir
man kann das wir sehen irgendwie gerade
mal 27 prozent von den leuten die meine
videos schauen haben mich auch wirklich
abonniert deswegen abonniert mich würde
mich sehr freuen
genau jetzt und locker machen ein
bisschen viel verlangt wenn sowas sind
aber auch noch wichtig ist und zwar habe
ich bei der koffer option auch noch mal
mit ein paar leuten gesprochen und ich
habe mich auch im internet ein bisschen
darüber schlau gemacht weil es mich
einfach sehr interessiert hat und ich
habe ja im letzten video schon gesagt
das eigentlich bei jedem körper erst mal
der zoll drüber guck ich weiß jetzt
nicht wie es bei der bahn ist keine
ahnung ob er auch wegen mir darüber
guckt und sachen wie geld drogen und so
weiter werden halt sofort rausgenommen
ich war aber immer noch der überzeugung
dass wenn man jetzt zum beispiel ein
handy im koffer vergessen hat und das
auch wirklich mit dabei war dass das
nicht vom zoll rausgenommen wird oder
vor den leuten die halt vorher anschauen
sondern drin gelassen wird und der den
koffer dann ersteigert hat im endeffekt
profil im internet meinten dass er so
koffer option auch schnell mal abzocke
sein können und eigentlich gar nichts
vernünftiges drin sein kann weil die
meisten sachen die wirklich noch einen
relativ guten wert haben werden
rausgenommen und dann als einzelaktion
wieder angeboten was man eventuell auch
verstehen kann weil es natürlich den
gewinn für das auktionshaus ein bisschen
ankurbelt die leute mit denen ich
gesprochen habe die meinten dass das
sicherlich manchmal der fall ist muss
aber nicht immer sein iphone iks war
zwar noch bei keinem drin aber es können
wohl schon mal so elektronische geräte
drin sein die auch wirklich was taugen
mit dem man einiges anfangen hören also
das vorweg ganz wichtig und wenn ihr
jetzt sagt sonst egal wir wollen das so
weiter koffer kaufst dann lass mich das
gerne wissen also dank fürs zuhören bis
hierhin und wir machen einfach mal den
koffer auf ich glaube ich setze mich mal
wieder auf dem boden das sei noch viel
schlimmer so also wir haben wir den
körper mache ich einfach
okay wenn man jetzt mal von oben drauf
schaut
ich mache das mit einem handy so sieht
deshalb von oben aus wenn wir erstmal
handtücher und irgendwelche klammerten
also und es sieht ganz so aus als würde
das schon mal benutzt
ich hoffe da ist jetzt wenigstens
irgendwas für jetzt drin weil wenn ich
jetzt einfach stumpf klamotten auspacke
die ächtung aber das ist dann halt immer
das risiko dabei hingegen wie mir der
position immer noch nicht zufrieden so
jetzt aber wir haben hier als erstes
diese hose schon irgendwie schon eklig
ist die jogginghose keine ahnung von
welcher marke klopp gar keine die hat
auch ein kicker was geht ab gebt euch
diese hose ich weiß nicht ob man das
sehen kann
aber die hat einfach ja klar muss man ja
sehen die hat einfach genau wieder ich
will das gar nicht abholzen genau da ein
loch genau im schritt ein loch dicker
was hast du damit gemacht also es ist ja
schon mal klar das ding gehört mit dem
jungen wahrscheinlich gerade im
pubertierenden alter oder so ich weiß ja
nicht
sieht man auch hier am nächsten shirt
wobei ich das glaube ich so ein
ähnliches hatte ich auch mal glaubt ihr
gab es nur bei h&m oder so ich checke
war kurz hier die größe xl
aber es sind irgendwie kleine aus gut
auf jeden fall schon mal in schillig ist
wird das beides kombiniert und dann im
penis unten raushängen lassen kann man
so machen so hinzu kommt dieses handtuch
schönes brot das handtuch
auch schon benutzt glaube ich ich will
das jetzt gar nicht unbedingt genauer
unter die lupe nehmen ist ja auch
logisch handtücher habe ich eigentlich
genug
das wären dann halt so sachen die könnte
man gut mal in die altkleidersammlung
bringen oder so also setzte man hat mir
den koffer von einer dame dieses mal ist
es vermutlich ja ein junger ist ja auch
kein großer körper deswegen tippe ich
auch hier mal so wochenendtrip oder so
für deine freunde besuchen kein plan
wir haben einen safe ist egal in welchem
jahrhundert lebst du denn er deutet
hoppla wir haben doch keine safestick
mehr so schnell kaputt gehen nehmen
ernstfall tritt zutage noch ein sehr
wichtig ich sehe nur immer wenn ich im
urlaub bin die ganzen asiaten laufen
immer noch damit rum als nächstes haben
wir hier eine mütze von campus campus
vtv oder so in weiß sie gefällt mir
eigentlich sogar sieht aus wie seine
tennis match oder so ich setzte mal kurz
auf so ein bisschen so könnte man die
tragen was sagt ihr wenn es gut aussieht
schreibt jetzt in die kommentare hashtag
cap sitzt dann haben wir hier auch ein
hand only widme ich habe keine ahnung
was das sein soll
ich denke mal eine gardine oder einem
nie das ist ja ich weiß ist das ist eine
tischdecke für ein tisch ja genau
schildert irgendwie absoluten gar keinen
kontext zu dem rest der da drin ist aber
gut ich glaube es gibt noch viel
gestellte dinge die man manchmal in so
kopf und findet vor allem wenn man der
erste ist der rein guckt also wirklich
sinnvoll mitarbeiter der hat sicherlich
schon alles irgendwo mal gesehen so dann
haben wir hier noch passend zu der
jogginghose eine joggingrunde sweatshirt
jacke von h&m habe ich ja eben schon
gesagt hast ja das glaube ich auch daher
und jetzt passt auf geht zwar auch ein
benutztes ja das ist halt raus genommen
ein billy boy kondomen haben wir auch
hier drin
ich habe es am anfang schon angesprochen
dass er oftmals hat die technik raus
genommen wird oder als elektronische wir
haben jetzt hier allerdings dass hier
was wir drunter ist es bis zum schluss
wir haben nach ist ray das hat nichts
mit technik zu tun das habe ich auch oft
benutzt allerdings nicht dass dann haben
wir hier für ja ich habe jetzt mal auf
also ich kann dieses dreht zeigt jetzt
nur in verbindung mit cannabis konsum
ein ganz schlimmer finger ist hat
anscheinend gewesen hier na ich habe ja
eben auch 14 jahre tippt wobei man jetzt
gut in der heutigen jugend ist das
natürlich mit 14 schon von normal
hier haben wir noch sprüht lasters gray
ich wusste nicht mal dass es sowas gibt
wir haben eine unfassbar erotische
sonnenbrille seine sonnenbrille hat
irgendwie jeder im koffer das war im
letzten jahr schon genauso da habe ich
den koffer aufgemacht und habe glaube
ich
direkte sonnenbrille gefunden und das
lustig ist ich glaube ich habe noch nie
gesehen wir haben noch einen
aufgerissenes kondomen dicker schmeißt
sie doch in höhe bis zu dummen wir fast
mal kurz zusammen nach meinem bild
koffer besitzer 14 jahre alt hat ein
loch unten in seiner jogginghose
reingeschnitten um seinen auszuholen
immer wenn er auf toilette muss oder
irgendwelche anderen aktivitäten
betreibt dabei benutzt er ganz wichtig
zwar kondome schmeißt sie verpacken
davon allerdings nicht weg sondern tut
es danach wieder in den koffer außerdem
konsumierten cannabis und hat irgendwie
offene wunden und das t shirt habe ich
gerade auch noch entdeckt als ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich weiß ich hoffe
wir können das jetzt noch nicht sehen
weil hier ist einfach das finde ich
schon geil aber ich schätze die person
jetzt einfach mal stumpf gesagt schon
als etwas eklig ein vor allem wenn man
jetzt diese klamotten da so alle linien
sid und wenn irgendwer sein koffer hier
wieder sieht weil ich glaube es gibt
nicht so viele menschen die mit einem
loch genau unten in der jogginghose
rumrennen meldet euch gerne und wir
haben hier noch nie so ein spiel würfel
wo leute dass ich aber wirklich geil
finde er hat
wir haben eine ps4 controller
das heißt was ich jetzt vermuten würde
kann ich auch von mir selber
er hat wahrscheinlich irgendwann freund
besucht über das wochenende und er hat
gesagt er komme dass ps4 zogen ich habe
aber nur einen von schorlemer bitte dein
noch mit der sollte sie aber irgendwie
ein bisschen schotter nicht mal gleich
ob das funktioniert also im endeffekt an
sich wieder ein lustiges nie ob es jetzt
60 euro wert ist ich würde eher sagen
nicht hier ist doch eine sonnenbrille
und noch davon
oder habe ich das krater hinein noch
eine sonnenbrille dabei auch extrem
stark hier schön gelb weiß ich noch
sagen wollte ob das jetzt eine 60 euro
wert war oder nicht ich würde sagen er
nicht aber es war lustig und darum geht
es ja auch nicht es sei denn das ist
jetzt die top controller
ich glaube an den kosten etwa 950 euro
nach so ich habe jetzt mal den
controller mit der playstation verbunden
überdies kabel damit man halt praktisch
nur anmelden kann nur normalerweise
müsste jetzt irgendwas angehen man hört
das ja auch irgendwie dass da nicht so
ganz
erhältlich ist er wird halt leider nicht
an wenn ich dir jetzt anmache müsste es
eigentlich auch hier geht doch nicht an
ja der ist schrott so war der typ damit
gemacht wird schade eigentlich eher
leute also wie schon am anfang gesagt
weil 10.000 likes geht es für mich zur
nächsten koffer aktion 250 kilometer weg
mit ein bisschen mehr geld in der tasche
auch nicht vergessen ganz wichtig würde
mich sehr freuen und wir sehen uns
morgen wieder da gibt es ein neues video
genau ich hoffe es hat euch unterhalten
das muss ich erstmal die ganzen sachen
die mir einräumen haut rein
ciao